a team of morons that's the focus of
tonight's angle
well now we know what it's like to have
bumbling half-wits running the country
now this just isn't a president for
getting words and names on occasion this
is an Administration responsible for
sparking a full-blown economic crisis
now despite being warned by Larry
Summers one of the only smart Democrat
economists left in America they tried to
Happy Talk inflation away
we also know that as our economy has
come roaring back we've seen some price
increases
some folks have raised worries that this
could be a sign of persistent inflation
but that's not our view our experts
believe and the data shows that most of
the price increases we've seen are were
expected and unexpected to be temporary
temporary and then they told their
minions in the press to claim inflation
it was all just a bunch of conservative
spin the talking point on the right and
especially among the Trump right that
there's this Biden inflation situation
happening in the country right-wing
parties scare mongering about inflation
and wages going up too high
well the angle predicted the inflation
bomb over a year ago that's what they
were talking about I guess and indeed
it's really really bad and even though
the left was finally forced to drop its
inflation denial reporters are still
trying to leave Biden wiggle room
while deeply troubling to the White
House the U.S inflation rate is nowhere
close to a record with nearly 15 percent
inflation in the early 1980s along with
soaring unemployment today a low
unemployment rate of 3.6 percent and a
strong demand for workers offers
optimism about the prospect for a
stronger economy ahead
optimism what is he reading all he
forgets is basic economics never learned
it when stuff gets expensive as it is
consumers pull back as they are and
businesses start laying off it's
inevitable
indeed over the weekend Larry Summers
veered back toward the r word
when we've had inflation above four and
we've had unemployment below four
essentially always since World War II
that's been followed by a recession
now in fact to avoid inflation he said
the FED would have to be extraordinarily
skillful and lucky and that they'd have
a very very difficult job ahead of them
now Larry's being charitable there these
people are neither skillful nor lucky
they're totally incompetent
and I know this is going to be written
off as just so another right-wing spin
but the angle believes that this
inflation spiral Biden created could
mean the end of the democratic party for
a generation
remember After Jimmy Carter it took
Democrats 12 years to shake off the
Carter hangover and win the presidency
again
so you would think that the Democrats
would see today's news as a sign that it
is time to Pivot to moderate to learn
but you'd be wrong
I'm doing everything within my power by
executive orders to bring down the price
and address the Putin price site in fact
we've already made progress since March
inflation data was collected your family
budget your ability to fill up your tank
none of it should hinge on whether a
dictator declares war and commits
genocide in a half a world away
to help deal with this Putin price hike
oh my gosh he's still trying to sell
that tired old line all right good luck
with that
now Harry Truman famously said the buck
stops here Biden says it stops more than
5 000 miles away and maripole
of course this is absurd
had Biden continued to keep America
energy independent would have gasoline
down at around two bucks a gallon I'll
be a huge relief to our families
and had Biden stuck with Trump's
economic policies would still have low
inflation and maybe even Rising median
income which Trump had
but his team adults refused to concede
that it's time to change course they
think it's just all a messaging problem
if we can only convince Americans that
the president feels their pain and is
doing everything possible
you're seeing a president that is
focused on uh keeping an International
Coalition resolved to do what is
necessary to counter Putin's actions in
Ukraine while doing everything that we
can to protect consumers here at home
Jake Tapper wasn't believing that you
see his face
well this is a complete and total lie
once they plan to sanction Russian oil
they needed to immediately open up more
federal land for drilling issue more
drilling permits green light Keystone
Etc generally they needed to flood the
market with American Oil and Gas
that would have not only helped
consumers hear and Tamp down inflation
it would have driven the price of oil
down globally and that would have hurt
Putin but no no no couldn't do that
they would have offended the greeniacs
just pray that someday you'll be able to
afford an electric vehicle people and
it'll be okay short of that our
secretary of transportation is pretty
much out of ideas
there's no quick or magic fix there's
always a lot of politics around gas
prices we're focused on what's actually
going to bring the relief so the
president authorized the release of the
reserves that's going to help
oh my God I can't believe the road
scholarship went to him it is an
irresponsible move to deplete our
reserves it's a self-inflicted economic
blow to the nation we're not
experiencing an emergency beyond our
control Biden did it to us so all their
spending the needless 1.9 trillion
dollars in coveted relief last year
passed by the way with zero Republican
support the damaging coveted protocols
the controls they put in place that
continue to keep our economy all
bollocked up
and the refusal to enforce the Border
all of it creates more economic strain
on American families
in a not so veiled swipe at the White
House's use of Putin price hikes to
explain away high energy costs Joe
manchin exploded today in a written
statement saying it is a disservice to
the American people to act as if
inflation is a new phenomenon
hard-earned wages and financial savings
are disappearing faster every month as
prices continue to climb while the pain
and frustration of spending more on
everyday items lingers over us all
especially among those who can't afford
at least that does not include Nancy
Pelosi
yet right now Biden not only refuses any
responsibility here his JV Squad at the
cabinet is doubling down on the very
policies that got us in this hole in the
first place
there's virtually no way to turn this
thing around now without triggering a
recession that's how stupid they were
and our next guest thinks we might
already be in a recession
Biden's Focus if he's capable of
focusing should be immediately trained
on fixing this economic mess
his stupid move against so-called ghost
guns yesterday total waste of time it's
going to have zero effect on crime rates
across the country
if he wanted to signal to Americans that
he really understands the severity of
what's Happening he could do something
really meaningful
every single person on his economic team
should be fired in fact anyone who
advised the president that inflation was
transitory should resign or be
terminated this means treasury secretary
Janet Yellen bye-bye Energy Secretary
Jennifer granholm never should have been
there in the first place mayor Pete at
Transportation he can bike away almost
all of his economic advisors should go
and he should start with Brian deese
and on what basis should Jerome Powell
be nominated as Fed chair by the way his
failure to respond quicker to obvious
inflation concerns should mean he steps
aside
the lift of list of these staff failures
is really long take up a whole hour but
there has to be accountability
we don't want to hear anything more
about the first woman this the first
that we need the best and the brightest
whatever your skin color whatever your
background running our economy not the
first and the dimmest
now the last time we saw such inflation
numbers it took three Democrat losses in
a row to get the party's attention they
were annihilated in 1980 1984 and lost
big in 1988. so who knows knows how long
it's going to take for them to wake up
this time I have no idea but in the
meantime Americans will have to budget
smartly organize passionately and choose
their candidates wisely
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else